cardi b
and husband offset's thanksgiving
celebration has ruffled some feathers
and now the wap rapper is saying she's
sorry the 28 year old rap star
celebrated turkey day at home with her
family
specifically she noted on twitter it was
12 kids and 25
adults and added it was lit
[Applause]
[Music]
videos posted to social media show the
large group
inside at cardian offset's house
enjoying a large spread of food
and dancing in the entryway having a
good old time
without any masks
problem is not everyone appreciated
cardi sharing her thanksgiving soiree
with the coronavirus pandemic still
raging and cases on the rise
many had to forgo or seriously alter
their thanksgiving celebrations this
year
on sunday cardi apologized on twitter
writing quote
sorry my bad wasn't trying to make
nobody feel bad
i just had my family in my home for the
first time and it felt
so good and uplifted me i spent so much
money getting everyone tested
but it felt worth it i wasn't trying to
offend no one
she also added that covet 19 testing
precautions were taken
specifically cardi says she and anyone
who works with her gets tested
four times a week oh yes honey
but even cardi's apology seemingly
didn't sit well with some fans on social
media
she later tweeted people be trying too
hard to be offended
i wonder how they survived the real
world oh
snappity snap snap but this isn't the
first time cardi has hosted a large
event during the pandemic
back in october she celebrated her 28th
birthday with a blowout bash in las
vegas
there was dancing twerking and even
this unique moment